cnbc
you all know i hate robots right i'm not
a robot girl
i watched the terminator young
very young and i was like
no thanks remember that scene in the
first terminator where his eye comes out
it's just that little red eye going but
i was like oh hell no i don't want any
of that up in my business no thank you
all right cnbc forget electric
toothbrushes tiny robots could one day
brush and floss your teeth
amazing no thank you
let's see though tiny robots okay let's
see
that's the focus of a new study from
researchers at the university of
pennsylvania who created prototypes for
microbots as teeny tiny robots that can
change shape to form bristles for
brushing or slide between your teeth to
floss how convenient
how efficient
and release an
anti-microbial substance what's that
define it tell me what's in it
that eliminates dangerous oral bacteria
from your mouth probably messes with
your oral microbiome too so then all the
good bacteria gets killed just fyi and
suddenly you're getting sick because
your mouth microbiomes all off just a
little extra info from me
now i look i'm like what is this
oh microbots composed of iron oxide
nanoparticles well that's just sounds so
wholesome
it sounds so wholesome and uncomplicated
so i look at this and i'm like i have a
few thoughts
i said first of all are you that lazy
come on now
you can't just floss you know my dental
hygienist who's amazing hi sparkle if
you're listening she tells me that she
has to floss her husband's teeth at home
she's like if i don't floss them he
won't chief lost loss i'm not kidding i
said you telling me
you've lost it she said i do i said wow
that's something
don't be lazy flush your own damn teeth
you know you're supposed to flush his
teeth three times a day every time you
eat i do not do that and it's super easy
especially like they got those little
picks and the picks you don't have to do
the you know yeah i do the long one
because i find pics don't my husband and
i are in a big debate about picks versus
floss it's like a whole big thing in the
house he won't use anything but a pick i
won't use anything about the floss so
what are you gonna do women versus men
we're different what can i say
but honestly my first thought was okay
how lazy are you my second thought was
have you not seen the terminator
aren't you worried about that little
microbot skin all of a sudden let's say
something goes wrong and all of a sudden
is it does it bite
does it is this something going on how
small is it where is it does it travel
does it record
you know i thought all the things i'm
not done yet tyler's looking away look
he's really eager i'm not done yet okay
then we got into anti-micro stuff that's
antimicrobial that reminded me of hand
sanitizer right you know what hand
sanitizer does it as an alcohol base
everyone has been using it for the last
two years like oh every time i shake
someone's hand i don't want to get the
copics so i'm gonna hand sanitizer kills
all the germs on your hand that includes
all the good ones so your microbiome of
your skin gets destroyed which means
that them would encounter something
that's more vulnerable that happens in
the mouth too okay a lot of toothpaste
things have things like sodium lauryl
sulfate all this crap in it so the oral
microbiome gets messed up all the good
bacteria dies and then you wind up sick
because a lot of sickness stems from the
mouth out just fyi so antimicrobial no
thanks i'm gonna pass
nanoparticles
um
no thank you all right so i'm going to
pass
on this
as much as i want to be sarah connor i
don't actually want to have to be her
when the robots come tyler i was told by
little birdie
that you thought this was interesting
and you might fancy a little help in the
in the to the toothbrushing department i
do wonder what would happen if you
swallowed one
would you if they said
all right you know how they do this
sometimes they say okay we're gonna just
have some volunteers
come and come down and um
you'll just be the guinea pigs for this
would you volunteer to be a guinea
absolutely not no i'm not a guinea pig
so you'd be like no it has to be
approved has to be like safety tested
listen we're already down the rabbit
hole we've already opened this box okay
have you like have you seen what's
coming out of boston dynamics these
robots can run they can do parkour they
can dance in unison it's a giant hive
mind we're already screwed i might as
well enjoy it so he feels like okay do
me a favor can you pull up some of that
stuff you just mentioned i need to show
people who don't know this [ __ ] is scary
i mean listen
i warned you in 1985 about the machines
i joke i wanted delorean delorean
doesn't like get up walk
you know
you've seen these movies
remember when you watched the movies
that were like a dystopian nightmare and
you were like oh that's never going to
happen well here we are in 2022 post
covered vaccine madness look at this
okay and just to show you the dystopian
nightmare can come true so here we are
look at this
okay
some people say oh it's so cool
we'll send those guys in to fight wars
it'll be awesome that's a robot
what happens when they turn on you i ask
and they never stop they never stop
they're probably stronger than you
it's hard to i don't know how you kill
them you know
honestly have you not seen the
tournament you know how hard it was to
kill that dude
think about it you got an army of these
guys and they're all computer programmed
right oh they're all going to behave
because they're linked to this system
and then what happens if and when the
system gets hijacked have you not
watched enough movies people the system
get hijacked it goes into the hands of
dictator or an insane person and now
those
look
i can't even can you do a backflip like
that no i can if you said yes i was
going to have you come right in front of
the camera and do it so good thing you
said no
well have you seen the robot out of
russia that can shoot a gun like and hit
the bullseye every time i mean every
robot can do this right but it's
we've already opened this box you've
opened the box you have open and listen
people i warned you
i warned you we're not gonna be a match
for those robots right so i i didn't
want the box opened i'm going to point
the finger and blame all of you who
thought it was cool to have the
terminator in real life all i'm saying
is john connor out there whoever you are
you better start working out you better
start doing what you need to do i know i
am if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here